the pigs have the advantage that it's
very easy to grow up pigs I mean we do
already do it for food with you and you
can probably get harvest about a dozen
different organs from one Pig
so that's very cost-effective we don't
yet know how to make a complex organ in
the lab and from say human parts in
principle human would be more compatible
but we're getting to the point where
we're already getting so-called
universal transplants that you can do
from any human to any other or to any
human to any human without having it
that find a perfect match the way it's
currently practiced and with the pig is
this taking a in vitro so the boy we do
the pig is we take we have a pig that's
engineered to be compatible and then at
the time of multiple human surgeries you
just take the appropriate organs out and
move them into the human that's the the
holy [ __ ] just the way you would for
human and human have a fully functional
heart you move it into a patient who
needs a heart or liver or a kidney